a question here and then I'm gonna bring  the microphone up to that side of the  room if we can go ahead hi hi I have a  very detail-oriented fanboy question  though oh dear you must hate those it is  with the maesters who all forged their  own links for the each subject that they  master Valyrian steel is not supposed to  be known had to be made but two of the  maesters have Valyrian steel links  Valyrian steel can be reworked they  can't make new Valyrian steel but as you  as you see when the twin swords of  Oathkeeper and widows wail are are  created in King's Landing you can take  existing Valyrian steel and rework it oh  you thought you had  [Laughter]  [Applause]